[Music]
coming next summer shazam antagonist
black adam will get his first dc eu
movie more than that with the signing of
dwayne the rock johnson as the lead the
hollywood legend has finally been cast
in a superhero or rather anti-hero film
watch this video to find out where black
adam comes from and what special
relationships he has with the
superheroes who will be standing in his
way
before we talk about the cast let's take
a closer look at the character of black
adam
most of you will probably be unfamiliar
with this guy but he's a recurring foe
of shazam and other superheroes in the
dc comics
however not every version of him is evil
he alternates between the roles of super
villain and anti-hero five thousand
years ago dad adam was born into slavery
in kandak his entire family was murdered
in front of him which is why the wizard
shazam chose him to become his first
champion
by uttering the name of the wizard adam
received his powers not from shazam
himself but from the day they shu hero
amon ze husi aton and mayan
he defeated his tormentors and became
the protector of egypt
upon the pharaoh's death adam developed
his own morals though
he thus liberated the seven deadly sins
for use against his enemies and was
given the name of cat adam or black adam
once the deadly sins killed all the
wizards except for shazam the latter
confronted his former champion
he was unable to take away his powers
yet he succeeded in separating them from
the human body and sealing them in a
scarab
thousands of years later a young
archaeologist named theo adam discovered
the beetle and unleashed its force this
took over the body of the scientists and
initiated a bloody vendetta against
shazam
this is as far as the backstory of black
adam goes
as in most comics there are of course
many different versions of the hero or
anti-hero however as the figure of black
adam has already been briefly hinted at
in shazam and judging from the images
shown in the first teaser this version
from the comics strikes us as the most
likely it is already known that shazam
will not play a direct role in the movie
nevertheless he is closely connected
with the story of the villain
even though the good wizard will not be
playing a role a lot is already known
about the cast and let us tell you the
dceu will see lots of new heroes but
first let's talk about black adam as
already stated he will be portrayed by
hollywood and wwe star dwayne the rock
johnson thus he will be following his
wrestling colleague john cena into the
dc universe the latter played the role
of peacemaker in the suicide squad the
heroes who will face off against adam
are also already known adam will have to
deal with the justice society of america
consisting of atom smasher hawkman
cyclone and dr fate adam smasher whose
real name is albert julian rodstein is
embodied by noah centineo he's one of
the lesser known names on the cast most
recently he made an appearance in the
romance films to all the boys and in the
remake of charlie's angels
carter hall aka hawkman is played by
aldis hodge he made his screen debut
back in 1995 in die hard with a
vengeance
the young ambitious actor contessa
swindell will be portraying the heroine
cyclone swindell is considered among the
few non-binary-outed celebrities in
hollywood so far they could be seen in
the movie voyagers which was released in
2021
the star figure and justice society of
america is played by none other than the
double 07 legend pierce brosnan he plays
the role of dr fate also known as kent
nelson he's a founding member of the
society moreover like black adam he got
his strength from an ancient wizard
which he discovered during excavations
additionally actors sarah shahi marvin
kanzari uli latu kefu james kusati moyer
bodhi zabangui and moment armor are
already noted as part of the cast sadly
little is known about their roles as of
yet
before we look at the potential
storyline let's take a closer look at
the justice society of america
most of you probably don't know much
about it unless you've read the comics
the jsa is a sort of predecessor to the
justice league or at least it appeared
much early in the comics its founding
members were adam dr fate flash green
lantern hawkman our man sandman and
spectre
three of them will now be featured in
black adam as well
adam smasher is basically the dc version
of ant-man however unlike his marvel
counterpart he isn't in need of a suit
rather he inherited the abilities from
his grandfather
he can change his size as he pleases
thus literally smashing atoms
in the comics rodstein is actually one
of black adam's best friends for a while
when he himself belonged to the jsa
the two of them turned their backs on
the group together as they had different
views of what justice meant
our next hero hawkman also has a strong
bond with adam he is the reincarnation
of an egyptian prince played by alice
hodge
this prince lived at the same time as
adam thousands of years ago his armor
was forged from a crashed spaceship even
granting the wearer the ability to fly
hodge can also access the knowledge of
all incarnations which has often proven
to be a potent weapon in the fight
against evil
cyclone alias maxine huncle is the
granddaughter of the original red
tornado who was also a member of the jsa
when she was a little girl she was
kidnapped by the mad scientist morrow
who gave her the nanobites of the second
android tornado
the bite seemed to have no effect on her
at first so she grew up to be a young
intelligent student at harvard
university until she suddenly developed
superhuman powers which she was not yet
able to control
this is how she destroyed her grandma's
garage by sneezing or how she woke up in
a twister as a result that jay-z decided
to take her in and help her learn to
master her skills
dr fate also known as kent nelson used
to be the son of an archaeologist the
two of them were exploring a pyramid in
mesopotamia during which they found the
tomb of the magician naboo the pair
mistakenly thought him to be dead and
upon his reawakening ken's father died
wanting to ease his grief the wizard
took kent in as his student and over the
years he instructed him about magic
when he completed his training nahu gave
him the helmet of fate on the cloak of
destiny together with the amulet of
anubis he turned into dr fate and was
able to keep in touch with the spirit of
naboo via the helmet who was able to
assist him with his future exploits
at present we can only speculate about
the plot
it is conceivable that the first third
of the film will illuminate the
background of black adam from ancient
egypt to his first battle with shazam
once he reawakens he will surely
continue to try to impose his ideas of
justice onto the new modern world
clashing with a jsa in the process
perhaps he will even join them briefly
as he did in the comics
whether there will be a big all-out
battle remains to be seen above all that
depends on what dc has in store for the
newly introduced heroes
in all likelihood they won't be able to
ultimately beat black adam as a
crossover will certainly follow in
shazam 203
after all one thing is certain when the
rock enters the franchise it's usually
hard to imagine it without him so in
turn if he destroys the jsa the four
members of the justice society of
america had a very brief appearance in
the dceu
we rather assume that they will be
defeated and weakened forcing them to
retreat for the time being in order to
take up the fight against black adam
again at a later point in time joined by
shazam
well we will definitely know more as
soon as the first trailer is out or at
the latest on july 29th 2022 which is
when the film is scheduled to be
released in us theaters
so that's it we presented you with
everything important related to black
adam and the justice society of america
what do you think what kind of storyline
do you have in mind if you have any
other ideas feel free to write them down
in the comment section below if you
haven't subscribed to our channel yet
you should do so now so that you do not
miss the first trailer of black adam
[Music]
you